we're here live from the Los Angeles
studios of Reason TV talking to
Christopher Cooper who does his
wonderful art under the name coop coop
is one of the great iconographies of our
time he brings tricked-out hot rods
monsters robots beautiful women of all
sizes and varieties some of them
devilish some of them not everywhere
from punk-rock fliers to gorgeous art
books too highbrow art galleries and he
is also I think one of the most ripped
off artists of our time something that
we're going to talk about here today and
thank you for being here coop also the
cover artist of the January 4 freeze
right yes you know we're gonna start
with an issue at the Nexus of art and
politics so we're reason likes to live
us intellectual property in art and
images now do you feel like people are
robbing from you when you see them bite
your style and you know how often does
that happen and what can you do about it
and what should you do about it yeah man
I don't know if we have enough time to
get into all of this but it's you know
on a I go between it because sometimes
you see something that somebody's done
that obviously is influenced and it's
it's you know it's it's kind of a
compliment but then of course other
times you just see somebody's just taken
something of yours without any credit or
any any payment and it's you know yeah
you feel like somebody broke into your
house and stole your stereo so I kind of
go back and forth on that a lot and I
mean I have in the past had to sue
people but you know typically it's been
well like I had to sue a record label in
Australia many years ago because they
not only ripped me off they ripped off
Robert Crumb because they took the cheap
thrills album cover like the layout of
panels and then replaced all of the the
Robert Crumb images with my images and I
I had to you know pursue that and that
took a long time I mean really though
it's kind of like the way that in the
grocery store they put all the cheap
stuff right by the front door because
they they figured they'd rather have
people steal the cheap stuff than the
expensive stuff and
I kind of feel like with the the era
that we're in now with the internet
there's a certain amount of that that's
just gonna happen yeah and there's
nothing you can do about it I mean even
Disney even Disney gets ripped off so if
Disney can't control it
you know one guy with a very limited
budget can't control it so what what are
your legal recourses is an artist like
you can copyright specific images and
well I mean you know I copyright
everything and yeah I mean you can you
can pursue it but you know it costs
money to to have a lawyer go after
people most of the time a simple cease
and desist letter will stop people from
doing that but I mean it's it's tough I
mean I know I was just talking to a
friend of mine who has a street wear
clothing label and his sort of trademark
image was just shamelessly lifted by
Jeffrey Campbell for a shoe design and
you know basically I think it's one of
those things where if it's somebody
bigger than you they sort of do it with
the expectation like well you know what
are they gonna do if they come after me
you know I've got more lawyers than they
have and whereas a lot of times with the
smaller people you know the like the
strangest thing that I've discovered is
I'll find just like some art student or
design student on the internet that'll
take an image of mine and do something
with it
and usually in case like that I just
send them an email and say hey that's
not cool you know knock it off and
what's really frightening about it is a
lot of times these are kids that have
that are either in art school or have
have attended art school and they're
like oh I had no idea that that was that
I couldn't do that I thought that if
anything that's on the Internet is free
and it's like that's kind of the
generational issue that we're up against
is like there's so much I mean yeah you
you hear a song you like you go download
it off of you know a website you you
know if there's a movie you want to
watch you download it off of a torrent
site so now a lot of people including
some people under the reason rubrics or
celebrate both the the freeness of
modern culture and sort of the culture
of appropriation sure you know
everything's out there in the world and
we're taking and rearranging it and you
know you had your own influences and all
that sure do you have any do you get any
of that feedback from people when you
lean on them yeah and and maybe that
whole punk-rock thing like hey man you
know we're just yeah in the world yeah
how do you react to that you definitely
get that and I mean I to a certain
extent I agree with that
and I mean I think that there there's
definitely a line between using things
as an omage and just outright just just
taking things and I mean I sort of look
at that on a case-by-case basis I mean
there's things that there's things that
I look at and I know that's kind of cool
that's you know that I see how they're
sort of reinterpreting what I've done
and then there's things where it's just
blatantly like they've just scanned a
page out of one of my books and you know
made something with it made a t-shirt or
something like that and that's just
that's just ripping off yeah
has there been examples where someone
who might have been in a position to
make more money than you ever could from
your work that you felt was was stealing
from you well like I said the record
label of the situation and I had I had a
similar situation with a software
company that did an ad campaign where
they they they had hired another artist
but basically it looked like they had
taken two or three of my images and sort
of stitched them together in this
Frankenstein creation which was funny
because I ended up as part of the
pursuing this I ended up talking to the
actual artist that they hired to do it
and he just he flat-out said yeah I they
told me what they wanted and I did a
drawing and then they came back to me
with something they had made out of
three of your drawings and said make it
look like this so you know that was kind
of the The Smoking Gun with that that
case but but I mean luckily I really
honestly I've only ever had to pursue
things legally on a couple of occasions
I've been really
really lucky in that respect and you
know most most of the other artists that
I deal with they understand this and
they they respect those boundaries yeah
I mean I think typically I think what
you see now is a lot of people that
there are these amazing tools on the
internet you know these you I mean you
can make your own movie you can do so
many things using your computer at home
that a lot of people you know we're
moving into this era of this just kind
of cut up appropriation culture where
people think if they just they take two
things they didn't create and stick them
together they've created something I was
just talking to the great artist coop
here about how he is achieved the
extremely rarefied status of a
successful working freelance
entrepreneurial artist talking a bit
about his career doing record covers for
labels like bump and sympathy for the
record industry and he was saying that
one of the keys was working continuously
since he was 16 yes and I mean it's you
don't that's the thing is when you you
are you're responsible for everything
ultimately and it you can't ever stop
you don't ever get the luxury of
stopping you know you don't get to you
don't really get to have a vacation or
anything and it's funny because I know I
know so many people that have you know
nine-to-five jobs and they look at and
what I do and they're like oh you know
you're so lucky you you just you you can
do whatever you want whenever you want
and it's like well no I probably work
more hours than you do you know when it
comes down to it and I mean because even
if I'm not setting at a table drawing or
standing in front of the canvas painting
I'm on the computer answering emails and
dealing with the business part of what I
do and you know that that stuff never
stops and it's I mean like anyone who
owns their own business I mean it's just
I have some I'm not selling widgets you
know and but it's a lot of the
principles are very much the same you
know in the Internet age there's a lot
of talk for with creative artists
you hear it from a lot whether you
should ever work for free what are your
thoughts if you're starting out on
working for free for exposure or
whatever that's supposed to get you well
that's actually a good question because
I that's something that I try to impress
on artists like younger artists that if
you work for free
you will always work for free because
nobody will ever feel the need to pay
you and you the thing that artists don't
understand too is that well in all
create this is extends to all creative
people is that as long as a company can
get something for free there's no desire
to pay for it and when you are willing
to do something for free that I would
charge for it ends up lowering the value
of what I do
ultimately and and it's hard to teach
people that because when you're young
and you're starting out you want that
you want to get out there and get your
name out there and I mean I'm not saying
I mean cuz I did a lot of stuff for very
little money I mean not when I was
starting I would do I would do a record
cover for you know a couple hundred
dollars and I did a whole bunch of those
and I mean I think that there's you you
have to you have to prove that there's
value to what you're doing and you know
that's part of how you prove that is by
charging a price for it even if it's
just you know a little bit I mean you've
got to charge something and gradually
hopefully if people like what you're
doing and you're successful you charge
more eventually now how did you segue I
first encountered your work in the 90s
always in a music contest yes Flyers
record covers uh how did you say way out
of that I don't think you're doing much
of that anymore if I'm correct and how
did you segue out of that and did you
always want to segue out of that well a
lot of it has to do with Robert Williams
and Robert Williams who is a huge
influence on me an amazing painter I
mean he he he was one of the co-creators
of the magazine juxtapose I mean he's
he's a big deal yeah
now that was a magazine that sort of
took the style of art you do which I
know people call lowbrow I don't know if
you embrace that term I'm sort of using
what's considered junky iconography in
American culture cars hot rods moms
robots and sort of melding it into a
gallery mentality is that yeah that's
good enough yeah and I mean Bob had
always sort of impressed upon me that I
needed to be doing work in a fine art
context as well as doing commercial work
and and I I had been for a very long
time and then about 2003 I just decided
like if I'm gonna do this I have to do
it like I can't continue to straddle
these two things I have to commit to
doing fine art full-time so I I ended up
at the time I worked out of my home I
ended up renting a studio at the brewery
in downtown LA and with the notion that
I was going to start painting these sort
of large-scale paintings and so the
first piece I did was a it was thirteen
six foot panels so it was 78 feet long I
had this goal that I wanted to do
something in the vein of names
Rosenquist like a big epic painting that
would just sort of you know throw the
gauntlet down and say okay this is what
I'm doing now I mean you're limiting
yourself with the Audion that's that's
big yes I I could not fit that in my the
idea was there were a few people at the
time that were sort of the whales of the
you know art Colette my art collecting
world and eye contact as I was working
on the painting I started contacting
them independently and saying you know
sending them photos and saying here look
at this you know I'm trying to finish
this big huge epic thing and if I'm
gonna finish it I need I need a patron I
need somebody to come in and step up and
say yeah I'm gonna buy this and
eventually that did happen and I had
someone purchase it or agree to purchase
it at about the halfway point of the
completion so at that point I was able
to just do the rest of the work and not
worry about what
what I was gonna do with it and that was
a really lucky thing for me and it sort
of saved saved my bacon you know because
I I mean I part of the reason I painted
it in segments was and James Rosenquist
did the same thing when he painted f-111
was he had the idea well if I can't sell
this as one piece I can take all the
chunks of it and sell it off to people
individually and that was sort of in the
back of my mind as well so this first
giant thing that went straight from your
studio to a private owner well to a
gallery no I did actually have a gallery
show but the work was already sold so
basically the gallery show is just a you
know a way to present it to the public
and let people see it and and the
collector who bought it is actually now
talking about building building his own
museum which would mean that it would be
on permanent display with a lot of other
people like Mark Ryden and Robert
Williams and other you know sort of big
wheels so is is the lobar art movement
very West Coast centric I mean as it's
broken through to to New York yet you
have any in din that world well it's I
mean Robert Williams has been showing
with tonisha Frazee back east at least
15 years now but I don't know it's funny
because I really feel like at this point
in New York City and the New York art
scene is kind of behind that's behind
the times like I think there's a lot of
amazing stuff happening on the west
coast that's been happening for quite
some time and I think here is now where
the kind of the heat is and I think New
York is still catch it's still trying to
catch up to what's going on out here
how do you measure that heat as a matter
of like the money that things are
changing hands for you know no no I mean
work is going for you know surprising
prices but I think more than anything I
just think there's a really lively scene
out here I think there's a lot of
artists producing really great work
there's a lot of really impressive
galleries out here and I think that the
collectors are starting to move towards
LA even before the
the the gallery's back east have and I
think a perfect example of that is
jeffrey Deitch who took over as director
of MOCA and has had you know a lot of
controversy which i think is unjustified
because he's what he's done is he's come
in and and made mocha a really
interesting and lively museum whereas I
think for many years it's just been
mired in this sort of inferiority
complex of worshipping New York and
worshipping Europe and I think he was
the first guy to step into that position
and say well you know MOCA needs to
focus on what's going on in California
because there's there's amazing stuff
going on in California and there has
been amazing stuff going on in
California that has been ignored by the
native institutions in in place of you
know paying attention to the same stuff
that everybody else is paying attention
to you back in New York and your style
which is is you know lowbrow in the
sense we're discussing the subject
matter is very pop yet it is is
representational drawing it's not yeah
inception in the way you associate it
with modern art I think it's starting to
change and the reason I think it's
starting to change is because I'm seeing
artists who are very much a part of that
blue chip New York world who are almost
sort of starting to they're starting to
do work that looks more like what you
would consider to be like lowbrow work
I mean representational art is making a
comeback and part of the reason that's
making a comeback is because collectors
are buying it yeah and I think that this
is another case where I think the
Internet has changed so many things
because I think now it's so much easier
for collectors to deal with artists
directly yeah and art and collect that
I'm seeing more and more collectors that
are they're buying things based on their
taste they're not buying things on what
a you know a gallery curator tells them
they should buy right another way around
the middleman that's a very represents
which has got to be good for you yes
know what now where I think the exact
same age I think both born in 68 where
we're out of your youth and your
interest did the kind of things you like
to paint and draw come from like why do
you draw what you draw well I mean you
know comic books obviously I grew up
with comic books I grew up with rock and
roll I remember buying The Ramones
rocket to Russia and seeing the back
cover drawn by John Holmstrom which is
this great crazy cartoon and I remember
looking at and and thinking oh you can
have a job like being an artist drawing
record covers maybe that's what I want
to do and I sort of ended up doing that
and and you know growing up I grew up in
Oklahoma so I grew up with like car
culture and you know that sort of car
hotrod culture has always been a big
part of my my life and you know it's
just sort of all of the yeah all of this
kind of pop culture that I grew up with
you know science fiction and you know
movies and was a big Daddy Roth a big
deal to you the oh yeah well you know
it's funny because I think that first
people of my generation I got a lot of
its secondhand
like through sort of the watered down
versions of what Roth did originally
back in the early 60s and then at some
point I read I was very young probably
13 or 14 I read the Tom Wolfe
essay about about Roth about Roth and
Barriss and that sort of clicked in my
head and I started kind of hunting down
that that part of the culture like sort
of the original stuff and and actually I
think where the big sort of rosetta
stone for that actually was Peter bag
who does work for reason was editing
weirdo which was Robert crumbs sort of
anthology magazine and Peter bag had
taken it over as editor
and he did a big feature on Edie Roth
and this is probably maybe eighty-three
something like that and just reproduced
tons of those original crazy monster car
drawings and you know all drawn by Ed
Newton and Robert Williams and you know
that was where like you know the
keystone clicked in and it was like oh
okay I see where this all this comes
from and what a connection of it all is
and you know the the style of all that
stuff just fit in so well with you know
cuz I was very much into like punk rock
at the time and and the the anarchic
style of it and this sort of outlaw like
you know middle finger in the air to
society really you know it it made a
connection with me now you've taken all
that and in an entrepreneurial way
brought it into the gallery world and I
your Twitter stream which i think is one
of the great Twitter streams of all time
I recommend everyone do it so I've I've
picked up that your politics for someone
from the art world and even the music
world tend to be a little more right
libertarian than usual and I I think I
sense a little frustration on your part
about being surrounded by so much goofy
leftism is that actor and what is it
like having right libertarian market
sympathies in a lefty culture world yeah
I don't know I mean yeah you do
obviously deal with that a lot in the
art world but it's it's I mean I don't
know my politics as that it seems like
as I get older I get more radical like
I'm almost like I feel like I'm almost
like a full-on anarchist at this point
like I'm just I'm so frustrated with
both sides of the argument at this point
and people's inability to look past this
sort of you know rah rah like my team
wins your team loses mentality to
actually look at what's happening and I
just sort of I I don't know I I'm I feel
like people are just like giving away
their freedom piece by piece
from that and they're not even getting
anything in exchange for it you know
it just it kind of makes me crazy and
and you know part of it is I don't know
I think maybe part of it is growing up
in a place like Oklahoma and you know
you I mean that's sort of there's sort
of like libertarian philosophy is almost
like part of your DNA if you grow up in
that part of the world really I mean you
just just like you just come you grow up
with that idea that idea of just kind of
leave me alone and let me do what I want
to do and I won't bother you you know
and that's that's just a very kind of
strong cultural thing from that part of
the world and I would think you know we
talked about the car that you drove up
into our Studios here today which you
pretty much made yourself right I'd say
it's a 1929 model a Ford sedan hot rod
and I I had a series of car projects and
then at one point I I had finished I
built a 55 Chevy pickup and I traded it
for the pieces of this car and basically
it was an abandoned project that
somebody never finished and I spent 98 I
spent about six years putting it back
together and rebuilding it and changing
things on it and of course I had help
from a lot of my friends sure and and I
got it on the road actually I got it on
the road a week before I had the opening
for the painting that I just described
and I've been driving it ever since you
know that's more or less I mean it's
it's a daily driver for me basically so
making cars making art rebel a runner
coupe thank you so much for coming to
Reason TV's la studios and talking to us
today it has been a pleasure and thank
you all for watching